in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Shawn
and Kim are with us hey guys how are ya
hey ever hear you welcome where are you
from
Spencer Indiana what's that near it's
close to Bloomington cool very cool
well good to have you thanks for hanging
out and you're here to do your debt-free
screen
yep how much have you paid off one
hundred and two thousand six hundred
sixty-four dollars I love it and how
long did that take you thirty five
months good job and your range of income
during that time it was just under a
hundred thousand up to now
165 wow great incomes what do you guys
do for a living I work on i.t I'm a
senior virtual a virtualization engineer
mm-hmm and I'm in cost accounting for a
medical device manufacturer great career
tracks way to go very well done and
you're obviously killing it so how do
you jump in three years from 100 165 new
job okay yeah I've been with the company
for almost 11 years and had an
opportunity to come up to go somewhere
else and does a right out about a year
ago so that was the that was the
increase so the IT world is just
exploding obviously yep okay very fun
will congratulations what kind of debt
was the hundred and three thousand we
were normal we had everything we had
401k loan we had just bought a brand new
van and then we had student loan that
credit cards home equity line and then a
couple of unsecured loans to Wow so
definitely normal yeah you had everybody
yeah they're just all lined up and just
just eaten your lunch yep so what
happened three years ago 35 months ago
tell me your story good we had just
bought in March of 2013 we had bought a
new van Sean wanted to something
reliable and I just went along with it
because I've been actually trying for
years to to do your plan and it started
with her her father he used to drive a
truck and used to hear you on the radio
and while she was still in college about
15 years ago he gave each of his
daughters a cop
Total Money Makeover right and she'd
read that and pretty much ever since
then been trying to get me to wake up
and you know okay so what was the
lightning strike what happened well I
think the van I think was it when we
bought that I kind I think I just
freaked out and so I just kept talking
about you more and more and I had a
co-worker at work that she talked about
you and so I was getting online and
looking at stuff and I don't know if I
just drove him crazy and so he finally
started listening we were we were well
above the national average on the car
payment the 600 plus dollar car payment
emot-- wasn't wasn't making her feel
very good and yeah yeah and I was just
thinking we needed to get a beter and he
wasn't listening he wanted something
reliable so we decided in July after he
finally got on board in July he went and
got we wouldn't got financial peace and
then we sold the van a month later so in
or a couple months in August we sold
then and it's hard for me cuz I I I'm
here as a top-of-the-line Honda Odyssey
I really liked it very bad yeah so now
let's talk about 35,000 bucks right yeah
there was about 38 it was actually even
used which I mean they hold their value
yeah good yeah for a few years yeah so
let me let me go back to you got a $600
car payment Kim is going bonkers
she's living in stress Ville what
happened inside your head Sean that made
you turn this corner well I finally
agreed to listen to a few of your
podcasts and you know once I once I
started listening I thought hey this guy
might be making some sense so I watch
some of your YouTube videos and then I
wasn't too long after that that I pretty
much bought in that you probably didn't
know what you're talking about okay and
we went through we did the FPU DVD home
study oh good
so then and after that you know I knew
we had to sell the vehicle and yeah that
took off about $30,000 off the top of
our debt right there
yeah then we end up getting a 2005 van
and so it was and it was still reliable
mm-hmm okay yeah very cool you guys I am
so proud of you guys you got to feel
great yeah yeah
I mean you gotta feel like just weight
off your shoulders yep definitely that's
a lot of money that's a big transition
how long have you been married four
years 14 years yeah this this has been a
hard three years though hasn't it yeah
it's been very hard and one of the
things that we were gonna bring up is
you know you talked about Murphy moving
in and through this whole three years we
had several things come up that could
have derailed us and discouraged at
certain times we had a basement that
flooded my air conditioner went out it's
never a straight line no it's not man we
bought got rear-ended and we had to end
up in another vehicle oh my gosh it just
you know there's things all along the
lines and we managed to every everything
that cost us money we were able to cash
flow and pay out of pocket we never had
to use debt to the handle any of that
stuff
so an insurance helped out to you
insurance helped out so yeah that these
guys tell people in your Financial Peace
University class if somebody asks how
did you pay off one hundred and three
thousand what do you tell them the key
thing is the key things are to get out
of debt my key is that your spouse has
to be it was just every time I turned
around it was you know I would be
talking about it and and then he would
be let's go buy some more stuff I could
make some more money yeah yeah and so
that was the big key but the budget was
also another big key you had to know
where your money was going or you know
that was our biggest thing because you
know we were eating out a lot and we had
no idea where it was going and once we
figure that out we were able to you know
Sean I see so many people standing where
you all are standing to do their debt
free scream that and it almost every
time their income has gone up during the
time they're working on their debt
snowball your income you took a better
job you said and that caused it to jump
up and it jumped up sixty thousand bucks
I mean it's legitimately a lot of money
would you have looked at that job with
that job have come along if you weren't
on a goal to knock out the debt or do
you think you were I kind of had your
eyes looking a
I had that kind of thing because you
were fighting this bear well I mean I I
had I was happy where I was I mean I
like the company it's a good company a
great company to work for
yeah but I always would tell people I'd
never ruled anything out so I was always
looking for opportunities and you know I
knew it had to be the right fit so does
somebody come to you or did you just see
it yeah I actually we had a vendor that
we used that we bought storage systems
from and he had a we had him another he
another client that he knew was looking
for some people okay and so that was
known about the introduction okay all
right well because I just wonder
sometimes how you know it's like God
looks down and says okay these two are
smart let's give them some more to
manage yeah all right very cool well
congratulations you guys and the kids
are with you what are their names and
ages shaitaan' is 10 Caitlyn is 6 and
kelsey is 3 all right now have they been
practicing from Indiana their debt free
screen yep yeah we practiced in the car
good at it they were earlier okay yeah
because we you know we're gonna be
scoring you guys now we got a you know
we've got to have kiddo screams loud
because your whole family tree has been
changed I might also mention that we we
use the financial peace jr. with these
guys too okay very funny
Elsie very fun all right Sean and Kym
Shaden Kailyn and Kelsey a hundred and
three thousand dollars paid off in 35
months making a hundred to one hundred
and sixty-five a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream okay let's
do our scream Kelsey three two one
way to go you guys very well done
awesomeness right there man I love it I
love it I love it open phones this hour
as we talk about your life and your
money you know you listening out there
if you are the spouse that's kind of
you're the husband you're the wife we
kind of go on Dave Ramsey stuff hey I
don't blame you I'd be the same way cuz
I mean I have the gift of cynicism you
guys but here's the deal
try it try it if you get out of debt and
you hate it you can go back in depth
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or $500,000
in economy